Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Buonasera a tutti,
come vi ha detto sono Yanez Borella,
vengo dal Trentino
e sempre da lì son partito
per andare a fare un viaggio,
perché sono un viaggiatore, un sognatore
e perché anche i viaggi, per me,
sono delle emozioni
e sono anche, soprattutto, delle chiavi;
e io vorrei sapere se sono delle chiavi
per i pregiudizi, scusate,
perché è questo che
praticamente io ho fatto,
con questi viaggi mi si sono
tolti tanti pregiudizi;
e quindi volevo raccontarvi
questi pregiudizi che mi sono tolti
con delle immagini, con delle foto.
Adesso vi faccio vedere un semplice video
e vi spiego il viaggio,
così capite dove sono andato
e cosa ho visto, in parte.
E dopo vi racconterò degli aneddoti
che mi sono accaduti nel viaggio
dove pian piano
mi son sciolti dei pregiudizi.
Intanto il video.
(Video)
Ecco: questo è più o meno
il viaggio che ho fatto.
E qui c'è la prima foto
che mi ricorda del primo pregiudizio
che mi si è un po’ sfatato.
In poche parole, eravamo in Turchia,
sulla dorsale del Ponto,
verso ovest della Turchia.
Siamo arrivati -
da questa ragazza qua proprio -
siamo arrivati in questo paesino
Siran mi sembra che si chiamava,
adesso esattamente - sì,
era lì il posto, più o meno sì.
E quando siamo arrivati li,
c’era ovviamente  -
sono arrivate tante persone
a vedere che eravamo lì
a chiederci mille cose:
Da dove venivate? Cosa facevate?
Perché eravate lì?
Ma noi, in verità,
volevamo solo cercare un posto
dove accamparci o dormire,
perché stava iniziando a piovere
e quindi avevamo tanta attrezzatura
anche da mettere via, coprire,
tutto quanto;
quindi abbian detto:
o ci accampiamo da qualche parte -
però sotto l'acqua è un problema -
o sennò dobbiamo trovare
un albergo o qualcosa.
E così dopo è arrivato tutto il paese,
in 20-25 minuti c'era lì tutto il Paese
che ci chiedeva, ci incitava;
e ci hanno trovato un posto
dove andare a dormire,
che era un albergo,
più o meno un albergo, lì vicino;
e così, dal niente,
questa ragazzina qua è venuta e ha detto:
ma perché non venite a mangiare con noi?
Ed era nel periodo del Ramadan.
Quindi io, da cristiano,
arrivare in un paese musulmano
ed esser invitato al Ramadan
mi son detto -
mi sembrava strano,
perché è una cosa abbastanza sacra
cioè diciamo è un po’ pesante,
mi sembrava un po’ esagerata;
però invece è stato bellissimo.
Mi sono trovato dentro in mezzo a tutti,
a mangiare tutti assieme,
ci siamo scambiati cibo
e ci siamo divertiti in inglese
diciamo abbastanza stentato
sia il mio, sia loro;
però ci siamo divertiti tutti
e abbiamo festeggiato questa cena,
perché si mangia una volta sola.
Quindi è stato bellissimo.
Praticamente mi ha aperto il cuore,
e mi ha tolto, soprattutto,
un pregiudizio grandissimo,
quello che io arrivavo da un Paese,
cioè dall'Italia, dal Trentino,
mi ero già fatto mille idee,
anche Giacomo che è
il ragazzo che era con me.
Se andiamo in un posto, i paesi musulmani,
avevamo visto delle immagini a dirci
chissà cosa succederà, cosa non succederà.
È successo proprio l'opposto.
Ci hanno invitato,
e ci hanno messo a nostro agio,
e ci hanno veramente addirittura
dato da mangiare, da dormire
e non ci hanno chiesto niente;
quindi è stata una cosa bellissima,
dal quel punto di vista
proprio mi ha aperto il cuore;
e mi ha dato coraggio e fiducia, anche.
Fiducia che siamo tranquilli
che stiamo percorrendo un posto,
ho cominciato a divertirmi
proprio nel viaggio,
perché prima hai tutte le tensioni,
i dubbi e dirsi che non ce la faremo,
cosa succederà è lì,
quella zona lì è più o meno insicura;
invece, alla fine ci si è
resi conto, proprio,
che più andavamo avanti nel viaggio
e più eravamo tranquilli,
e le persone ci apprezzavano
per quello che eravamo,
anzi diventavano quasi
degli idoli per tanti
perché non erano abituati
a vedere due ragazzi
messi così, con dei carretti
di 100 chili dietro,
con una bici elettrica
che era in condizioni -
dopo 10.000 chilometri, immaginatela,
la bici non è proprio ridotta benissimo,
quindi erano tutti cosi
e la gente ci acclamava, ci fermava lì
e chi ci dava quello che aveva;
e quindi questo è stato, diciamo,
il primo aneddoto che mi ha colpito
proprio perché è stato
abbastanza emblematico,
cioè essere in un Ramadan
a me ha colpito tanto, ma anche a Giacomo.
Dopo ne abbiamo parlato,
è stata una cosa bella.
E dopo è successo un'altra cosa.
Adesso passiamo qua, siamo in Georgia,
praticamente stavamo
attraversando sempre, ma pioveva.
Nel viaggio,
su cento giorni di viaggio
che abbiamo fatto,
50% abbiamo preso l'acqua
tutto il giorno e abbondantemente,
infatti abbiamo avuto anche dei problemi,
perché le bici erano elettriche assistite.
Avevano un motore,
perché il carretto, come vedete,
è abbastanza grande,
quindi pesa più di 100 chili.
Quindi era complicato portarlo in salita,
quindi avevamo un motore
che ci dava una mano
con delle batterie che si ricaricavano
con dei pannelli solari.
E in più, dietro avevamo tutto,
gli sci e tutta l'attrezzatura
perché oltre a attraversare i Paesi,
ne abbiamo attraversati 12,
scalavamo una cima per Paese,
per l'Associazione Donatori
di Midollo Osseo
perché è una cosa che io
mi sono sempre portato dietro
in tutti i miei viaggi
per promuovere questa associazione
che ne ha bisogno,
perché qua in Italia siamo in pochi.
Quindi sarei contento
se diventassero di più i donatori.
Quindi c’era dentro tutto l'occorrente,
quindi veramente era pesante.
Quando siamo arrivati in Georgia,
le strade erano così,
non erano asfaltate, erano molto fangose.
Ci siamo fermati: pioveva,
diluviava come sempre.
A un certo punto io e Giacomo
ci siamo fermati e abbiamo detto:
cosa facciamo qua, in su non andiamo,
in giù ormai non riusciamo più
a scendere con queste bici qua.
Ci siamo fermati lì dieci minuti,
ci siamo messi al riparo
sotto una piccola tettoia
e sono comparsi due ragazzini,
tutti bagnati, che giocavano,
e dopo un po’ ci hanno chiesto
cosa facevamo lì e dove eravamo lì,
gli abbiamo detto: noi dovremmo andare
dall'altra parte del passo
però il problema è che non riusciamo
con queste bici qua,
sempre in inglese maccheronico.
E loro ci hanno capito
e dopo dieci minuti arrivano,
arriva un furgoncino verde,
un furgoncino russo,
non so se avete presente
un po’ tutto scassato,
e scende Ercole.
Oddio, adesso siamo finiti,
siamo spacciati.
Adesso cosa facciamo,
è il doppio di noi, ci porta via tutto:
basta, andiamo, andiamo a casa.
Bene, prende in 20 secondi,
100 chili tra bici e carretto,
le prende, le carica
e ci fa: venite, su su!
Siamo saliti su questo
camioncino, di  dietro
e c'era un suo amico davanti
che chiacchierava, intanto;
ma non ho mai capito cosa abbiano detto
perché parlavano in Giorgiano,
e io non lo so il Giorgiano.
E loro non parlavano inglese.
Comunque siamo andati avanti.
È venuto anche il ragazzino con noi,
siamo saliti fino a 'sto passo,
a un certo punto si ferma,
e ho detto: ecco adesso siamo spacciati,
adesso ci portano via,
ci mettono -
invece si ferma, si ferma in un
piccolo chioschetto fatiscente, esce,
viene fuori con tre quattro birre
e una stecca di sigarette così,
e dice: dai, beviamo e fumiamo!
Ma io no, non fumo;
però le birre stento a berle
perché dopo so già cosa mi fanno.
Giacomo ha bevuto una birra
e tutto quanto,
siamo scesi, ci hanno portato
fino alla strada che era asfaltata;
e li ci ha scaricato
le bici e tutto quanto,
e noi abbiamo tirato fuori il portafoglio:
chiedici quello che vuoi,
ci hai dato una mano,
ci hai "salvato la vita",
in quel momento li.
[E lui]: No, ma stai scherzando?
Abbiamo dato una mano
a una persona che aveva bisogno,
per noi è normale, è cosi.
E avevamo fatto, dico,
due ore, tre ore di strada,
quindi non era proprio poco.
Noi amici ci siamo guardati.
e abbiamo detto:
ma veramente, stranissimo,
cioè una cosa pazzesca.
Da noi si dice:
neanche il cane muove la coda
se non ha una motivazione.
Invece lì ci hanno portato,
ci hanno trascinato lì
dall'altra parte del passo
e ci han lasciato andare.
E In più ci hanno anche offerto da bere,
ci hanno caricato la bici -
Un altro pregiudizio
sfatato completamente,
quello che non è detto che devi per forza
volere qualcosa in cambio,
per quello che fai.
Quindi questo mi ha aperto veramente
gli occhi ancora di più,
ed ero ancora più curioso di viaggiare,
ancora più curioso di vedere altri posti;
ma infatti questi 100 giorni che ho fatto
sono volati alla fine.
All’inizio son partito,
siamo partiti tutti e due
che eravamo stanchi
perché avevamo cento giorni
per arrivare in Cina,
non perché volevamo fare il record,
che quello non ci interessava,
è perché proprio il visto cinese
aveva 90 giorni di tempo
da quando lo timbravamo con il passaporto,
quindi in 90 giorni
dovevamo entrare in Cina,
perché sennò non ci facevano entrare;
e quindi avere un altro visto
era un problema.
Quindi abbiamo detto:
in 100 giorni dobbiamo arrivarci.
E avevamo una montagna
che erano 7000 metri da fare
che sapevamo che non era così agevole,
quindi dovevamo darci del margine.
Quindi erano abbastanza tirati,
quindi all'inizio eravamo distrutti,
completamente distrutti,
perché facevamo 150 chilometri
e poi dovevamo andar
su in cima, far le cime:
avevamo prefissato tutto:
però, più andavamo avanti,
vabbè, lascia stare che magari
eravamo un po' più allenati:
però ci siamo emozionati,
avevamo talmente tanta voglia
di vedere cosa succedeva il giorno dopo
che non ci rendevano conto neanche
che eravamo sempre in moto,
perché tutte queste cose che capitavano,
tutti questi aneddoti
ci davano sempre più voglia di curiosità.
Poi io sono uno
che si emoziona, lo vedete,
infatti mi sono emozionato;
prima ero abbastanza titubante
e ero talmente in adrenalina,
proprio in adrenalina.
come quando fai le gare che sei
in adrenalina completamente,
che non capisci niente.
Ero così, ero proprio pieno di emozione;
E quindi volavo,
proprio con la bicicletta,
per andare a cercare altre emozioni.
Infatti adesso vi racconterò
un altro aneddoto,
che è questo, che è particolare.
Vedete che facce che avevamo?
Non so se queste facce -
se le vedete, scappate
più che dargli una mano.
Qui eravamo, siamo andati in Uzbekistan,
arriviamo vicino a Malik,
è una cittadina a ovest dell'Uzbekistan
nella Valle di Fergana,
chi lo conosce un po’,
verso il Kirghizistan;
e lì è successa una cosa particolare.
Siamo partiti la mattina,
sempre per fare una cima
che si chiamava Chingam,
che era sempre a nord, circa 2500 metri;
però a parte quello,
siamo arrivati che avevamo
le batterie scariche,
un po’ perché eravamo col carretto,
un po’ perché avevamo fretta,
perché avevamo dei termini
per arrivare in altri posti,
quindi siamo andati veramente veloci,
siamo arrivati a metà
e le batterie erano quasi finite
e muovere quel carretto lì
senza batterie -
abbiamo provato,
penso che dopo dieci chilometri
potevamo andare a dormire
perché non avevamo più forze,
quindi dovevamo per forza
cercare una ricarica.
Cerca, cerca, abbiamo trovato poco,
abbiam trovato lì un ristorante,
che sembrava un ristorante.
Abbiam detto: andiamo lì e chiediamo.
Siamo entrati lì, si è aperto un mondo.
Siamo entrati a chiedere se volevamo..
basta , siamo diventati -
tutti che ci guardavano
perché c'era un matrimonio,
questo qua era il papà della sposa.
Quando siamo arrivati lì, ho detto:
oddio abbiamo sbagliato,
andiamo via sennò qua -
ma no, siete pazzi!
Ci han preso dentro, cominciarono
a darci da mangiare e bere.
"Dovete ballare con la sposa",
in quelle condizioni lì.
Eravamo in condizioni pietose:
e quindi io ero
in imbarazzo, e anche Giacomo;
poi, ad un certo punto
ci siamo adattati, divertiti,
cominciamo a scambiarci,
poi non tutti avevano
il cellulare per le foto,
ce l'aveva uno.
E continuavano a chiedergli:
fate la foto con lui,
fate la foto con lui.
Questo povero Cristo era lì
che continuava a schiacciare foto,
ne aveva una sola,
e tutti: fai le foto
anche tu, me la passi?
Quindi è diventata proprio una fiera,
è stato bellissimo,
a me mi ha emozionato tantissimo:
e questo è anche un altro pregiudizio
perché penso che qua, cioè non lo so qua,
ma in qualsiasi parte del mondo,
se vedi due persone così
che si presentano
al matrimonio di tua figlia,
io non penso che tu
li fai ballare con lei.
Anzi dici: non diamo niente,
non vi compriamo niente,
penso gli chiudi la porta.
Invece con noi non è stato così,
l’opposto proprio:
è venuto, ci ha invitato,
poi ci ha chiamato,
adesso qui non si sente neanche il film,
lo vedrete nel filmato dopo leggermente,
però non si sente
che ha cantato Toto Cutugno:
ha cantato tutti i cantanti italiani,
Toto Cutugno era in primis.
Quindi è stato divertentissimo,
era tutto una sinfonia.
E lì mi ha aperto il cuore,
proprio tutto perché ho detto:
"Madonna, non credevo
che ci fosse un posto così";
e quindi questi pregiudizi
mi hanno aperto, veramente,
tante e tante idee,
tante immagini, tanti pensieri
e dico: "mio Dio, qua siamo in un posto -"
Ed ero talmente contento
che siamo andati avanti in questo viaggio
veramente velocemente
fino a arrivare sul Peak Lenin,
che dopo li, era un 7000 mt,
c’erano tante altre cose,
comunque tutto quello
che ho vissuto fino a lì
è stato entusiasmante e anche dopo.
E adesso volevo far vedere un mini video
perché volevo raccontarvi, più che altro,
che di questo viaggio che ho vissuto
non mi sono rimasti i chilometri,
i metri di dislivello fatti,
contare i paesi che ho attraversato,
i followers che ho guadagnato
o tutti quei numeri
che non hanno significato.
Le cose che mi hanno dato più significato
sono i sorrisi, gli innumerevoli abbracci,
le innumerevoli risate
e gli innumerevoli scambi con gli occhi.
Tutto quello che mi ha riempito il cuore
del fascino delle persone
che ho incontrato,
perché sono ancora -
cioè, anche noi ci emozioniamo,
però loro sono ancora
più incontaminati di noi,
su alcune cose;
quindi si emozionano di più
e ti trasmettono emozioni.
E queste emozioni sono,
per me, la fonte di vita.
Se vivi senza emozioni,
come han detto anche altri ragazzi prima,
non ha senso vivere;
e quindi questa è una cosa
che mi ha entusiasmato.
Quindi anche i viaggi per me
devi viverli con le emozioni,
emozioni che ti danno
e che tu dai agli altri.
Quindi queste immagini
che vedrete sono questo.
Quindi ve le lascio,
e dopo ci sentiamo tra un secondo.
(Video)
Erano queste le emozioni che volevo dire,
quel ragazzo che parlava così
era quel signore che cantava Toto Cutugno.
Era questo.
Grazie a tutti, è stata, per me è stata
un'emozione vera e propria:
infatti ho sudato,
perché sono veramente emozionato.
Grazie.
(Applausi)